Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Scoot Scoot!
Now this game is cool
Because the name is cool
That's how life works
You don't need any other justification besides that!
I wanna play this game
BECAUSE IT'S GOT A COOL NAME!
OKAY?
Okay so in this game, you're a scooter scooterererer
You're a scoo-
You're a scootererer!
YOU'RE A SCOOTER SCOOT!
SCOOTY-DOO!
SCOOT SCOOTENATOR!
SCOOTEN-HABEN
YOU'RE A SC-
SCOOT
SCOOT (x2)
SCOOTER SCOOT!
Anyways, I'm assuming you're riding a scooter.
I literally don't know anything about this game!
When I say I only picked it because the name was cool,
You're God damn right!
I don't know a God damn thing about what you are supposed to be doing!
But apparently, hitting bollards gives a time penalty.
Go fast through speed traps for a-
Oh, shit.
Oh...
Okay...
OH JESUS!
OH GOD!
Ahh shit...
Shitty tits
Okay...
BEEP!
Ah, fuck
BEEP
Oh, are these the bollards?
Is that what that's called?
Is that close to "bollocks"?
I dunno.
Okey lets-
Lets just give that another go!
NO, I'M NOT GONNA RESTART MY TIME!
I got a perfectly-
Oh, God
It's s-
Woh
Holy shit!
Oh, that's awesome!
Oh, it reminds me of Absolute drift!
Aw, that's cool!
Whoops
Well,
That wasn't correct
But we're gonna-
Oh, God damnit!
Its so powerful!
AAAGH!
OOHH GOD!
Okay, hang on
I'll just swing around and
I'll get-
I'll get it on the second pass
Don't worry about me! I got it!
Ah-I got it! Ah!
Love the music!
Ah, shit.
Hang on!
Boop boop boop boop.
YAAAYY!
Okay..
[sarcasm] Man, I hope I pass my test!
Speed boost!
Agh, shit. God damn it!
How am I supposed to know!?
Nooo.
Poopy doops.
Round and round and round we go!
Whup-
Now straight, apparently!
I'm afraid!
Imma sca-
I'm scared as to what could come befo-
Oh.
Oh, I-
Oh!
Oh, I see what we are doin' here!
Oh, I see!
Okay!
Welp, tha-
Whup, that's another bollard!
Okay, no bollard for me!
It's so-
Like, there's, like, no pressure
Oh, there IS pressure sensitivity! [Mark is a dum dum]
Oh, I'm just so ham-fisted that I couldn't stop
Hammering down the trigger!
Oh, I'm an idiot!
Oh, that's the answer to all my problems!
I'm stupid!
Well, even though I know now, I still can't control it.
RAMP IT!
Okay, that was less than anti-climactic...
Well you're not gonna tr-
Ah, fuck!
God damnit!
You're not gonna trick me!
I'm gonna trick me!
I'm the only one that trick me trick-do!
Hyeh!
Fuck.
Oh God-
Fuuuck!
Ah, God damnit, no!
Ah, thread the needle!
AAAGH
And, time!
Oh, sh-
I gotta go again?!
I GOTTA DO IT THREE TIMES?!?
HOLY SHIT!
I am gonna die.
Okay.
Here we go-
Nice and slow.
Nice and fast!
Nice and slow!
Shit
Shit, shit
Shit, shit, shit
Shit
I tried to stop!
...Okay, I didn't try to stop, but I tried to not do that thing!
By doing absolutely nothing differently!
I- All I did differently was start screaming!
And somehow that didn't help my problems...
So I don't know what the fuck to do!
M 'kay, nice and smooth!
Nice and smooth!
Here comes another turn!
And a f-
Wooh
Ooh!
Didn't hit the bollard that time!
Its like I make it-
Ah, shit-
Fuck.
God damnit!
Don't worry!
I erased all the progress that I could've possibly made with my skill! hep..
Well,
Imma takin'-
I wanna take a victory lap!
Excuse me while I hump this, whatever the hell it is!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
You like that?
You like that a lot?
*imitates scooter noises*
Wabooski!
Oh, boy!
K, through the-
Through the bollards again!
Shit-
Well.
Apparently I did it.
Okay..
We are comin' up on the-
Oh, shit
We are comin' up on the end of this lap!
And we're doin good so far!
We gotta do it again though
Which is
Awfully wonderful!
And I love it!
And this game is goin'-
Oh, fuck me, c'mon!
Agh!
If I had to give any intelligent commentary on the game,
I'd say that it's. . .
It's well made! And. . .
If I was any sorta good,
I-
Ah, fuck
God-
I'LL GO AROUND!!!
DON'T MIND ME!!!
I DON'T KNOW WHERE I'M GOIN!
I'm goin' around, apparently
WELP
I guess I'll go this way then...
Oh, shit. . .
okay alright (x4)
Return to the back!
What it is
What it does
*Gibberish, bad rapping*
Ah, fuck it
Woh
Oh, now we got it!
Oh now we got it, because I'm not hammering it down again!
Ain't that lovely?
Ain't that lover-ly?
Shit
Okay
Alright
Alright!
We're gettin' better!
Like, shockingly!
Not even me being facetious
But we're getting better because I got a better feel for it!
And more control!
Doin' wonderfully!
Wohh!
Ah, fuck!
Hang on
I'll try that again
Whup
Nope
Not quite
Well!
I seem to be stuck!
Aww, shit!
Welp!
Its an Austin power situation!
Hang on
I'll get it eventually
Maybe not
Fuckin' physics based bullshit. . .
There we go!
That was my best lap!
How in the shit?
Five minutes and twenty two seconds?
I think the record was, like, two minutes!
How does anyone do that?
*Sigh*
I'm proud of it
Alright, fine
"Markimoo"
I'm gonna re-try it tho!
I'm gonna do this!
Better. . .
K, ready?
Here we go...
Nice and gentle!
Cuz if we can just avoid time penal-
Ah, shit
Fuck me then
(Gun it x3)
Sloow
Ah, there's a brake!
Oho!
If only I had know that this-
This particular vehicle had brakes attached to it!
That woulda been wonderful to know!
I'm, like, legitimately concentrating here!
Right, y'know?
At first I was, like,
Accepting my fate as just being terribly bad
But now I'm like,
I really
I really wanna try to do some sort of good
I'm not gonna be world record, that's for God damn sure, but...
At least I can be "Markiplier Record"
Which is
Obviously not anymore of an accomplishment
Shit
God damnit, why do I keep swinging that
WIIIDE
FUCK!
Okay, there we go
Wee!
Oh, that was smooth!
That was smooth!
Oh, that was smooth as MY butt!
Ooh!
That was less smooth! (x2)
That was more like my other butt.
Shit- god damnit, I forgot
Oh, get off!
Stop your proclivity to hump!
I'm trying to go for a record here!
NOT RECORD NUMBERS OF CONES HIT!
I HIT THAT MIDAIR, ITS BULLSHIT!
OH, FUCK OFF!!!!
God damn it, my headphones came off but I cant fix it because I'm in the middle of a race.
I've-
I've never done
Guy...(?)
I-
I'VE NEVER EVEN DONE WORSE THAN THIS
Like
When I was doin' it before!
what happened?!? I came out of such a good!!
oooooohhh fuck yoou
oh fuck off
HEAAAAAAAAOOWWW
WOOH
Ok apparently thats how thats gonna be
OK
Three - eleven!
A VAAAAAST Improvement
AMIRITE?
OK If I hadn't hit so many cones
And if I hadn't been so stupid half the time - I would have done better.
Im gonna give it another try - I wanna give it a go *SIGH*
Fucking COOOOOOOOOOCK
* RAGE *
YEAH YEAH ALL OF EM FUCKING ALL OF EM - AND THEN I DIIIIED
WHATTT?
WHAAAAAAAT?
WHAAAAAAAAAT??
FUCK OFF WITH YEH
EEEEEEEEEEEH
Alright we got this
OHHHHOHOHHHH God damn it
* screech * FUUUUUUUU
AUHHHHHHHHHHHH
*loud grunt* WHY AM I TRYING?
Why am I try harding my eyeballs out
*sigh* Oh fuck, OH FUCK off!
FUCK OFF!
*SCREAMS*
*SCREAMS AGAIN*
I AM SO MAD AT MYSELF -
For even bothering with this
Why am I trying to get a good (voice crack) score
I DID A FINE JOB LAST TIME
EUEUEHEH FUCK YOU *BREATH* FUCK YOUUUUU
EUHHHH WHY AM I TRYING
WHYYYY??
I WANT TO NOT DO THIS
Ok we had a goooood lap, good lap
Now I'm not restarting no matter what
Even if things get horri- AWWWWW
FFFFFFFUUUUUUUUUUUUU
*screeches*
Even if things get horribly fubber nuckedd
FOR ONE REASON OR ANUDDER
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY WOULD
EVERYTHING HAS GONE SO SMOOTHLY for me in the past-
Oh shit - fuck you dick
NOOOOOoooOO DOONAHT
Come on
God dammnit THERE -  two thirty FIVE!
MAAAAAAAA SHHH BETTER
I'm not gonna play this enough to get good to do another thing
So that is the END of Scoot scoot FOR NOW
In all honesty despite my rage I am just-j rat in the cage
(coughs)
Despite all my rage this game is fun
I actually do enjoy this alot
I can't remember if it cost any money
Maybe it was like one of those pay your own things ...
Either way ill put a link in the description below
If you can beat my high score MORE POWER TO YOU
I APPLA*voice crack*UD YOUR EFFORTS
YOU'RE A SHINING STAR AND BETTER than me so
Take that home with ya
So
thank you everybody so much for watching
n' as always i'll see YOU in the next video
BYE BYE
OH OH THATS A BEAUT,  OHH THAT WAS A BEAUT
YES I don't know if thats good or bad but I did it-
Fire me-OW
FIRE ME ow - where am I going
OHHH its a nightmare